you
Tony Fadell how you doing Aaron great to
see you good to see you Robin
it's been too long absolutely we we
start each session off of the handshake
so just one just one handshake we can
close with a handshake - okay yeah no
hugs
we like you want anything I prefer okay
it's been a bad day
oh say more lawyers you know when you
got to deal with lawyers all this yeah
here okay so I'm so what we're talking
about with the industrialist dilemma is
what changes when we move from an
industrial world to a digital one and
how should industrialists respond and
how our disruptive companies and
technologies sort of forcing them to you
know sort of bear this new reality so I
think just maybe just to back up though
it'd be great if you want to give like
the founding story of nessam you
obviously have a pretty incredible
background maybe if you want to weave
any of that in and in terms of it led to
nestin just the level set the the
conversation okay sure
so you know nest was kind of born out of
20 years of experience more than 20
years of experience I've had in Silicon
Valley and around they're doing
technology around the world and you know
there was a lot of lessons that I
learned leading up to starting this
because I had other startup companies
before then that's some utterly failed
miserably okay I also had startup
divisions of major corporations four
hundred thousand people I was like
reporting the CEO building you know you
know like what honey oil might be
building or who knows what competitors
trying to build underneath it so I've
been in the big big company world and
the small company world for over 20
years and seeing all kinds of different
angles and failed a lot so going into
nest I wanted to take all those
learnings and and apply them and
understand you know when do you when do
you shift the market when do you get
bought you know all those different
things so bring that to bear so Nestle
really just was born out of my
frustration that over ten years I was
trying to get a thermostat just to heat
and cool my you know my place up in
Tahoe and remotely because we'd go up
there and it would take six hours to
warm up and we're all freezing and you
know and that and then we had kids and
they didn't like that at all
so that was just how it started it
started from you know I saw
the iPhone coming we were development of
the iPhone it was building this house in
Tahoe and I'm like wait a second the
world is going to dramatically change
the control of the world is going to be
in your hand at all times everything in
your world so how is it home gonna
change and so I wanted to make it the
most green most connected home possible
and that is where you know going through
every single piece of designing the
house and understanding every mechanical
system electrical system I said that's a
problem that's a problem and we created
a whole list of all the problems that I
saw and during that four years of design
and development I kept looking for new
things new products from those same same
things and most of them some of things
like refrigerators and dishwashers they
got better but things like thermostats
smoke detectors various other things
we're just kidding we're not getting any
better
they were just um you know commodity
based products and so I was like why is
this so I started designing my own and I
was like wait a second there's so much
better ways of doing this they were
trying to make basically put calendars
on it and photos on the thermostat but
they never made a beta the thermostat
they just wanted to raise the price of
the thermostat but it didn't make it
better or easier to use so fast for they
said okay here's a nice interesting
product we could build I was like any I
know the team I know the technology I'm
and then I'm like who could build this
so I looked at all the incumbents and
none of them had the requisite
technology as you said you know all of
these different functions and especially
in that consumer marketing and not
consumer retail right so wasn't just
about technology it was about all the
other things that go to market to
actually be able to talk to the consumer
because you no one cares about
thermostats today guess what a lot of
things people didn't care about before
but until you market it and you market
it right and you make it attractive and
you make a real great value proposition
that's when the world wakes up and goes
wait a second I've been duped along all
these years I want to do I want to
actually have the choice I don't want to
tell what this installer guy you know
mr. buttcrack you know like we're gonna
believe that yeah you know it's gonna
what heat says put this one on the wall
and that thing on the wall is like a $49
unit he sells it to you for $250 he
won't tell you what it is because all
the spews are different you can't
compare them so the the honeywell's of
the world were designing their products
for
installers not the consumers they were
marketing them to the installers not the
consumers they were making them the
cheapest things possible the most
technical thing you know features
possible and they forgot all about the
users and that was that was kind of the
insight there was I have a problem I
can't get it I can't get better ones why
is that the technology is changing
dramatically they don't have the
capability and they don't have the
communications plan to be able to tell
the world about it I was like and then
wait a second how BIG's the business Oh
twelve million units are sold a year in
the US alone just two residences that's
more than video game systems that's more
than most most stoves ovens
refrigerators I was like wait a second
oh and by the way 50% of your energy
bill is controlled by it you know it
compares like toilets or anything
yeah it's because toilets most people
don't buy for frames about it's a very
very low if you're very very low thing
so um but yeah so that was the whole
thing so looking at the marketing
looking at the channels looking at the
house technology I just need you realize
that the direct-to-consumer was like
this like this advantage that was almost
kind of impenetrable it was not about
direct consumer it was direct to
consumer marketing but fulfilled by a
channel and yes there was a direct
component for them from nest com that
we'd sell right but what all of these
connected products are and Kickstarter
things you're finding out is you must
have retail you can't just go direct if
you go direct you're going to you're
going to get killed unless the people
really know what they want for price or
whatever like you're buying a freaking
iphone cable or something not a problem
but if you're trying to communicate to
people especially in the home you need
to interrupt them where they shop and
they don't usually interrupt they don't
you can't interrupt them online they
need to learn about it we're educating
them there's a better way and you need
to do it where they go when they touch
things and they can learn about and so
we had to have retail we only started
with three stores one when we when we
got going but the results you know the
money just kept flowing in and then it
was now we have like 15,000 points of
distribution by physical distribution
plus amazon plus our own detail stuff so
that actually
you basically just made our second
performer last session obsolete which is
the end of retail so you need retail now
it might be showrooming yes but you need
to have something where people will
touch it it does not go away so Ron do
you agree with Ron Johnson on his
philosophies of retail
you mean enjoy or retail retail oh yeah
retail yeah absolutely
okay um what um what so are you where
are you at in terms of going down that
list of things that you want to digitize
and disrupt I mean you you mentioned two
products that you had identified when
you're building your house and they need
to stop short of telling us about any
other products that you well we have
three products now a product family and
look if you look at SKUs and all the
stuff we do for various countries we
have about 20 SKUs so it'sit's actually
it might seem like it's a little bit but
there's actually a lot to meet four
regions but remember our business model
is not just sell hardware at a profit
okay and it's also not selling data okay
our our products are all about full
feedback loops between control and data
to inform control and back to data so we
are connected sensors business we have a
sensor we have control and we have a
connectivity to get the data in and out
and new software updates that's what we
really are in okay so first it all
starts with a really great product
people don't buy platforms people buy
products before yes there was Windows 95
and all the other stuff people bought
that today no one buys platforms
typically not even corporates a lot of
new corporate startups and stuff they
buy services they buy products so you
have to start with a great product but a
great product isn't enough you don't
want to end up like a Samsung which is I
gotta just keep selling you new hardware
because guess what I'm not gonna sell
you new thermostat every two months like
you can't a smartphone it's gonna be
there for 10 to 12 years that's on
average right smoke detectors 10 me at a
7 to 10 years you got to figure out how
to monetize those things once they're in
the home and that's with services and
that services both from enterprises that
can pay like utility companies or
insurance companies or consumers to pay
so if you look at it is modeled after
the iPod model which is sell a great
piece of hardware have great apps and
services around it and get them to build
into the ecosystem to buy into the exes
and start with a great product buy more
services buy more products buy more
services and it goes around the horn
like that that's the way it's designed
as an ecosystem and have third parties
bond in to make that echo system even
more you know substantial so Tony as
you're building a company where you've
got these software competencies these
hardware competencies data competencies
how do you as a leader attract the kind
of people to come in and how do you have
these various functions and groups work
together or not work together to deliver
the best product to customers well the
thing is we're still in the very early
stages of this so because there's still
so many standards that haven't been you
know you hear about these things feel
like there's in compatibilities data and
cabal ways Wireless and compatibilities
you know all kinds of other things so
our goal first and foremost is we just
tell them about our mission one about
the thoughtful home one about saving
energy one about saving lives though it
you know keeping people safe and secure
people are like you know employees like
I want that they don't want to go and do
you know Pavlov's dog make it like you
know a slot machine in Vegas you know oh
I'm gonna just keep clicking and keep
giving you money you know a lot of
people were you know jaded by that and
they didn't want to go work for
companies like that so a big thing is of
our mission and that was before we were
part of alphabet slash Google people
just want to join for what we're trying
to do and that continues to this day
that continues today and now they want
more on the design front they can see
that we're doing a whole end-to-end
design that includes marketing retail
all of those pieces and they want to
really live in it and it's still small
so they can touch all of the different
functions they can learn about the
different functions and get a real
working knowledge for how these kinds of
companies work because there's very few
of these full ecosystem like companies
that are small that you can learn about
there's there's been a bit of a trend
recently in the valley which is because
you can use contract manufacturing and
and because we're certainly probably all
in agreement that the hardware and
software the combination is
kind of potent that Silicon Valley
becomes the center of a lot of the new
hardware disruption what what do you
think that Silicon Valley what do you
think Silicon Valley gets wrong about
starting hardware companies what what is
still hard about the industrial world
when you think about building kind of
hard technology and do you think that
the Honeywell's of the world you know
are those competencies you know useful
enough that they can get in the software
fast enough or is that still not
relevant for them to be leveraged mostly
the software engineers and where they
get their software is from Bosch from
all these third parties most of that
stuff comes from a third party supplier
they outsource all this stuff over the
years they they got rid of it and now
they procured it like oh it's just a
system here and it's just a system here
but that's not what it means to make a
new experience you can't buy it from a
third party if if we sort of had to
force you to the fix of a Honeywell yeah
or how would I do at Chrysler I mean can
it be done sure so and what would you
lever leverage in that process what of
the strengths of those companies or at
least the good parts of that DNA would
you take advantage of well first you
need to create a new division and it
needs to report directly to the CEO I've
done this three times so I've been
through this it has to report directly
CEO you must have air cover the
antibodies always said in no one likes
the up-and-coming upstart that is going
to prove these other things wrong the
CEO wants to prove all of these
different divisions that they're wrong
they don't know what they're doing
so you must have CEO coverage at all
times and hopefully it's a CEO that's
going to be there more than three or
four years because these are long-term
visions these are long-term cultural
things you are going to break the
culture gonna have to have a different
set of incentives for those people who
to join because of the risk involved
okay you're going to have to have
different culture policies everything we
did this at Philips we did it at Apple
even we did it at Apple a typo and then
the certain key lieutenants have to be
told by the CEO this is it this is my
pet project no one's touching it and if
in this is what I was told is if anyone
gets in your way give me a call right
away and what would happen is the CEO
would then call one person or two people
who got in the way and that quickly got
a
because they got their heads chopped off
and that was like a freight train scum
and everybody in the organization
outside of our the division in the
organs they said if this guy comes to
you or this team comes to you give them
what they want because you don't want to
be standing in the way you have to have
that kind of you know air cover if you
don't you're never antibodies we'll set
it you guys have been it you've seen it
until you've seen it in different places
right does that person make friends in
that organization or friendship oh no
it's lonely at the top it's lonely at
the top
you just you just go okay and you just
you know Jeff Williams you know I
remember the first meeting I had with
Jeff Williams and back then he was a VP
or whatever and I was just I was a
consultant as a consultant apple and I
love Jeff so don't get me wrong he's now
CEO oh and congratulations to him but I
just I didn't even know who he was
it's like you're gonna be doing this for
me but he's like who's this guy talking
to me like that it's like yeah you're
just gonna do it you just had to own it
and go get on board or get out of the
way because if you're in the way I'm
gonna call some winnings
smash your head in so watch out the axe
is coming full of violent metaphors I'm
no no no no you know
make sense okay
and then includes marketing and sales
and all kinds of other things
is there Nets a real problems there
anybody whose head doesn't need to be
smashing you need to do a couple of them
okay and then that changes the culprits
corporate I'll put in the head on the
poster everyone can see it
absolutely everyone has to know that
this is incredibly important to the
company in the future so one of the
readings we did for today was about
corporate venture capital yep and if
Google was an investor in Nast correct
yeah and surround like a right and so
certainly as you look at the
organization how did that relationship
develop you know as they as they become
an investor and how you want to kind of
stand in your journey and having a you
have a corporate investor but you want
to build the organization the way you
want how did that that information flow
back and forth that ultimately they
decide hey we think one of you know
acquire this asset what was that like
for you as the CEOs of business we worry
about them trying to suck information
out that they might do that I wasn't
worried because they had Android at home
at time and these other things but I
also think about
VCS and many VCS have conflicting
investment
if you look at some VC the larger ones
they actually have investments that will
compete against each other so I thought
of it more like that I also knew kind of
where the Android at home team was and
you know I kind of you know you know
you're in the valley long enough you get
you get the whispers and understand
what's happening or not happening at a
certain firm or team so it was really
about you know are are they really
supportive of the business are they
gonna really lean in are they gonna be
able to help this was very clean
incredibly clean it would look like any
VC deal you'd see on say Hill Road and
they were incredibly supportive so I was
not you know of course you have some
worry about it but as we went down the
road more did more trust was built up
and then when it came time for our next
round we were raising the round and then
Google said well are you sure you don't
want to do it with us instead here's all
the other things we can offer you
besides money
what so I asked the two-part question
originally we went more to the second
part so on the first part though what
what do you see as hard about building a
hardware software company and is that
something that any any founder could
just like can the can the incumbents
just get disrupted by anybody who you
know calls up Foxconn and says hey
here's a CAD file I want you to build
this thing or like is there a competency
still in Six Sigma and in in in sort of
maybe traditional you know quality
processes and which parts of that do you
sort of do away with and which parts do
you still harness and have you been able
to fuse those things into your culture
yes okay so great question so yes you
can get contract manufacturing they span
the thing from they'll design it all for
you to you just tell them what to do and
they'll manufacture for you and you can
go everywhere in between that capability
is growing sourcing is great all of that
stuff's great at the end of the day if
you're a little startup and you're
dealing with the Fox cons of the world
they don't give a you're too small
the business doesn't matter no matter
how much you're gonna grow they won't
care they'll take your business and
they'll give you the c-minus team you're
gonna train all of these kids who
usually didn't even come out of college
yet and you're gonna train them and
you're going to work with them if you
use them so you have to know the teams
you're going to because if you're gonna
really outsource and and you don't have
a huge business they don't really care
they'll just take it on and we'll see
we'll place a bet it's cheap
and you're gonna train our people
anyways because what's happened over the
last 20 years is we've trained almost
all of them to do what they do did it
and now they're coming back and
competing with us because like oh yeah
it's easy just like what happened with
Japan Korea Taiwan we train them all we
leave then they take over the businesses
from us that's exactly what's going on
in China so how do you make sure that
doesn't happen
you want to make sure you keep your IP
and the things that are really necessary
to be competitive outside of their hands
you do not give it to them so test
fixtures and test procedures and
software for testing it's incredibly
hard to do don't give it to them don't
give them the source don't go anywhere
near it we give them a black box and say
press this button and if it it lights up
green it's done press this button and if
it lights up red reject that one and go
rework it so you want to keep certain IP
pieces totally under wraps and not given
to them you might even do sub component
tree somewhere else that where it's
there's a lot of intricate manufacturing
techniques and robots and everything
else and then just give them that one
piece that's already fully assembled and
tested to then continue on so you have
to understand what you're going to how
you're gonna interact and when you're
when you're like a Kickstarter thing or
whatever else people just think they can
just throw it over the wall and it'll
just happen and it won't atoms are so
much harder than bits cuz every single
product we make is like a piece of art
every single one has to be hand tuned
you know how the dial feels all that
stuff it is not easy and we have to make
you know millions of them electrons you
can copy them and make a million copies
overnight and they're exactly the same
right it's not that way all the sourcing
you're getting for different sources of
materials for metals or whatever they
all come with different tolerances and
specs how did it get together and fit
and work properly it's much harder than
we have a whole team of our own people
working at the contract manufacturers
and the sub component suppliers to make
sure the quality so then the only reason
that the incumbents in this space though
then can't like as if atoms are so much
harder than bits and Detroit knows how
to you know put together all of the all
the pieces to build a car why is that
the not the hardest part of the of the
process and the self-driving you know
software and the you know the Internet
connectivity that becomes at least more
marginal to the overall car production
well it will become a component it'll be
a component I system you can bolt on
today just like you can do for stereo
equipment or nav systems the issue is is
that we're in this we're in this
transition away from from that right now
you can't buy the modules they know how
to buy modules and install them okay but
today you have to design all of them and
you have to design the experience at the
same time it's not the same of just
bolting it on your car materially
changes now they can do them they can do
the manufacturing and those kinds of
things then great they do an amazing job
I'm always in awe it's the most
complicated consumer product in the
world is an automobile I'm always in awe
I'm daunted by if I ever had the
opportunity to build one but if you look
at it
they've been module buyers they haven't
been module creators and and real system
creators and that's a very very
different thing when you're creating
systems and that's why Tesla is so
different than the other the other guys
as you look at its data and services and
the positive reinforcing mechanism that
you described earlier how do you decide
where to take those competencies as you
build them and where to go to next do
you try to kind of sit look at kind of
close to Jason sees around the home do
you try to think of well maybe this
could be applied to manufacturing this
could be applied to other things how do
you think about where you take the
organization over the next five to ten
years well the big thing here is you
need to worry about the ecosystem the
platform you can design all these
one-off products and you can be a gadget
maker just like I mentioned these other
companies are but if you really want to
truly do the system you need to know
when you're gonna apply step on the gas
from new products or new services new
applications and if you looked at the
kind of how iPod happened it was
Hardware one year or two years then
after that it was services and the
hardware was new but it was not he
didn't have it any kind of great new
features in the hardware it just had new
software to take advantage of the
service features then in some point we
came back to the hardware and it would
go round and round like that and that's
the same thing as you have to know where
you are in the gestation cycle to know
where you can apply your resources where
are we right now where are we right now
we're in the software phase software
platform phase so and and but to the
services point and you kind of mentioned
that yeah
the thermostat you only upgrade every 10
or 12 years yeah it's got to be some
other interim business model can you
maybe just share some potential examples
of what other service business models
can you layer it on once you have the
the user or the data so so what we have
the energy partners business which is
rush hour Awards which is demand
response we have seasonal savings that
should explain the demand faucet demand
response very simply companies have to
our electric companies have 20% of
excess generation facilities that are
only around for about five to ten times
a year that they turn on to get when
everybody wants cold air at the same
time which is in the summer right in
Texas and now all in the southwest
everybody wants energy at the same time
so they have to spin up other plants to
be able to supply that peak if you can
shave those peaks so they have less
transmission nut needs transmission
capability they need to build less
generation facilities they need to build
and less very expensive generation
facilities that they have they could
rather decommission instead of keep on
line keep hot that saves them a ton of
money you know the cost of a kilowatt
hour goes from you know four hundred
five hundred dollars to eight thousand
dollars during a peak period hmm so they
have to usually if they don't have the
generation facilities they have to go
buy an 8000 but they're selling it to
you as if it was five hundred so they
don't like that
they don't like these unexpected things
especially as the earth is warming up
right so how can you cut that down and
through rush hour rewards we cut out 60
to 70% of those Peaks Wow so that saves
them a ton of money our customers stay
cool because it's only within a one and
a half degrees Fahrenheit that we
modulate they don't even know the NPS is
in ninety five ninety seven in the
places where we run the service and then
you just get a check cut ten and what
they do is it's called rush hour Awards
because they get incentives so either a
per event or per year if they're opted
in and they can control this thermostat
at any time if they're not feeling good
there is a sense of what what the
economics are to you in terms of the
economics to us are you basically a per
per thermostat charge okay that's really
annual per thermostat is that something
that I mean it sounds like it has to
have been a new concept to nest but is
that I mean
appliance makers in the past been able
to track any of that or get any of that
value coming back to them to monetize
that yeah no they haven't because what's
typically happened again there are the
incumbents we're selling the hardware
directly to the utility and then the
utility says I'm gonna control it I'm
gonna turn off your your cooling I'm
gonna I'm the master right and we're
like that's not a balanced approach
people you know consumers might like the
cheque but they're gonna hate it when
they're not comfortable and so us being
the middleman has and being really the
advocate for the consumer has put the
consumer in front of these utility
companies instead of you know b2b
companies we'll just sell them anything
right one of the one of the distinct
advantages you guys have is you're
you're you're competing against
traditionally sort of product or
manufacturing or hardware companies and
and you're adding a systems approach by
thinking about software and data but
then you're adding even a broader
systems approach with an ecosystem
correct and that I mean there's nobody
at I don't I mean maybe not nobody but
there's very few people at Honeywell
that think ecosystems and no they they
want them closed
locking rightly Honeywell processor can
you maybe just paint a little bit of a
future of what that little picture of
the future for what a nest ecosystem
looks like we don't have to pay we don't
have to paint it here it's already there
yes we have 15,000 developers something
like that doing that today and we have
hundreds of integrations and over 20% of
our customers already use works with
nest integrations in their home so 20%
of our customers are linking our
products up to other people's products
and services so we you know and that's
only been in a year and a half old
problem so why are we doing it number
one we can't build everything we can't
build every refrigerator or every washer
and dryer it just and that's not gonna
happen and almost all of those companies
because they're industrialists they
don't understand software they don't
understand services servers those kinds
of things they need to work with
somebody right right now they could have
their own standalone silo but that's not
going to work because they have to work
with other people's products from other
brands so you have to find a new good
neutral party to put all these things
together and not play favorites so but
then in a sense you turn the
industrialists into the app makers of
the feud exactly so thus they survive
and everything's fine
yes exactly oh great okay
if they choose to enjoy if they choose
to embrace is anybody not embracing it
yeah sure there's a lot of companies oh
and there's even utilities not embracing
it okay
well hopefully that will change when the
PUC is make them change right
okay Tony Fadell thank you thank you